we want to make it so unattractive to do
the type of work that they do that
they'll go somewhere else and do
something else
you can't fight markets when a market
reaches a certain size you can't fight
it the san diego tunnel task force is a
special multi-agency team composed of
agents from Homeland Security and Border
Patrol and the Drug Enforcement
Administration and what they do is
pretty much in the name investigations
to detect and discover tunnels but also
to actually conduct investigations into
the people that are actually behind the
tunnels the task force has discovered
almost 200 tunnels under the border
since 1990 little tunnels like this and
huge tunnels like this why is it tunnel
so attractive while we estimate that the
cost to build a tunnel is in the
vicinity of a million possibly to two
million dollars they recoup that
moreover in just one day if they're
successful smugglers have been using
tunnels along the us-mexico border since
the Prohibition era
there are tunnels out in Mexicali in
Eastern California border region that
bake that probably close to a hundred
years that were developed precisely to
move alcohol across the border today
it's not very different one of the best
ways to avoid law enforcement is to go
underground literally David shirk is the
director of the justice in Mexico
project at the University of San Diego
and his research contributed to this
recent government report finding
California's border to be as leaky as
ever but he takes issue with the reports
conclusion that the solution is simply
more funding for enforcement agencies I
have no doubt that authorities are able
to do more when they have more resources
the question is can they do enough the
one constant in the last 40 years of the
war on drugs is that where there is a
willing buyer there's a willing supplier
for every new mile of fencing that we
put up for every extra thousand or ten
thousand Border Patrol agents that we
throw it into the area there's always
some traffic
or some organization out there who is
figuring out how to maneuver around
those obstacles this is probably
attributable to changes in smuggling
patterns and changes in organized crime
in Mexico Garcia and his team have spent
decades searching for border tunnels but
every time they fill one up a new better
tunnel emerges way back to TJ to Mexico
as the Sinaloa cartel has moved in to
Baja California their organization has
been credited or blamed with the
construction of some super tunnels I
mean very long very deep professionally
constructed tunnels we were essentially
playing whack-a-mole hit it here and
then another time would pop up and you'd
hit it there it was a decided approach
by all the partners to do a long-term
investigation and try to go after those
people responsible this reflects a
broader shift in the government's
overall strategy in the war on drugs to
take down kingpins and dismantle the
cartels they recently took down the
notorious el chapo guzman of the Sinaloa
cartel who happened to have an elaborate
series of escape tunnels underneath his
home but shirk says the strategy comes
with its own pitfalls was when the
government decided to take on drug
traffickers that the drug war became a
literal war and we've seen an enormous
amount of bloodshed in Mexico precisely
because of internal splits of these
organizations competition from other
organizations that has been a direct
result of government efforts to take out
top leadership how does the arrest of
someone like chapo guzman affect how we
do business it changes things in the
sense that there's a kingpin that's no
longer there but we're not so naive to
think that there isn't other people
there that can step right in chapo
guzman was really one of a number of
different leaders of that organization
that have held it together we've only
taken out part of the leadership's like
you're taking away one of the eyes but
the other eye is still there and so that
it's not a full decapitation of the
organization it's not even a lobotomy
they're trying to enforce a law
that is difficult if not impossible to
enforce because it doesn't have buy-in
from a very significant portion of our
population I think it's kind of like the
little boy at the stickiness thumb into
the you know leaking dike or the dam you
know at what point you just give up I
don't think that anybody that is truly
embracing law enforcement as a career
ever wants to give up garcia may think
of himself as the boy with his finger in
the dike patching a leak until backup
arrives with a more permanent fix to
avert a flood but there's another way to
think about America's 40-year drug war a
tiny tunnel appears you fill it then you
see a bigger one so you hire more people
to fill the bigger hole of course
there's eventually an even bigger tunnel
with ventilation professionals dug this
tunnel so you need a special team to
keep up with these professionals on the
other side and now it's just you and the
professionals you both know what you're
doing you both get a little better every
time the tunnels are getting bigger and
better but at least you're finding them
you are finding all of them right we
want to make it so unattractive to do
the type of work that they do that
they'll go somewhere else and do
something else
we know that's a long hard road and you
know we may never be successful in our
lifetimes but we have to continue to lay
that foundation now